so in the last couple of videos we've
talked about benjamin franklin as a
printer we've talked about him as a as a
successful public leader as a successful
businessman but we also know benjamin
franklin and we've talked about him as a
successful writer with poor richard's
almanac but but
there's this other side of benjamin
frank which kind of makes him larger
than life which he was also a
a significant scientist
yes you know he would have thought it
was strange that you could
aspire to be a great citizen and not
care about science back then you should
know about science so he did everything
from trying to track the gulf stream he
discovered ways to use dark fabrics to
absorb heat he creates a great franklin
stove a fireplace that's a wonderful way
to uh be more efficient in terms of uh
uh you know heating a room without
getting it all smoky and and also not
wasting the heat i think you know
normally in a fireplace all the heat
goes straight up and out right right and
it sort of had a nice little top to it
that guy little plate that got very hot
and so he was a very practical inventor
even things like you know bifocals he's
riding along the road one day and he
keeps wanting to read but then look up
into the distance and he says well why
don't i have two pieces of glass melded
together one that's good for reading and
one that's good for looking out in the
distance so
it wasn't like he was a research
scientist he was just a practical
inventor what makes him into a great
research scientist is when finally
you know in the 1740s and early 1750s he
starts doing the electricity experiments
and this is important this is actually
something i learned when i read your
book on benjamin franklin is that
i mean this was real as you mentioned
this was real research this was you know
something that
understanding the nature of electricity
the nature of lightning and what and how
to manipulate it yeah we think of them
as a daughtering old dude flying a kite
in the rain
but in fact those electricity
experiments were the most important
experiments of that era not only uh not
only for the practical use of them but
for the theory up until then people had
created static electricity you know when
you rub your sweater against a piece of
glass and lots of sparks come out and
they thought that electricity was two
different fluids and they had two
different names for the fluids
franklin realizes it's a single fluid
and he creates the idea of positive and
negative
plus and minus those type of things so
that's a flow of electricity and he does
that with his electricity experiments
that really begin in the 1740s
partly as a parlor trick because he
loves it but then he realizes no let's
study this stuff electricity and it was
a real issue i mean people were dying
because of lightning you know i remember
in the book there was a particularly
funny i forgot the exact quote where he
said you know the the churches get to be
tend to be hit disproportionately so it
seems like god is not favoring them
right well you know what they used to do
was they would sanctify the church bells
so that it would ward off the lightning
and they would even sometimes store
gunpowder inside churches with
sanctified bells
but the lightning kept hitting the
steeples of the churches and people in
germany italy and then the united states
you know there were these huge
explosions lightning was a great scourge
of the time you could ward off lightning
they would sanctify a metal bell and put
it at the top of a tower bingo it did
not work and franklin has a wonderful
line in one of his letters which is
you'd think we would try something
different and see if that worked and so
franklin
looks at sparks that he's been looking
at from his electricity experiment and
he's been you know creating these little
sparks with the static electricity but
then using a wire to make it into a flow
of electricity and put it into a battery
he gives us the name battery because he
puts it together a lot of laden jars
which is the way they used to store
electricity
and so he's looking at the similarity
between sparks
and lightning
and in his notebook he makes a little
chart he said well sparks have these
qualities they're fast they jump there's
a sulfurous smell they make a little
crack and lightning has the same
qualities and he does a wonderful
notation at the bottom of that notebook
page very scientist like he says let the
experiments be made
and that's how you get the lightning
experiments and he literally i mean you
know it's a little bit of a
i guess you know it sounds like a legend
now but he literally did go out into a
rainstorm and tie a kite with a silk
thread
to a kind of a key attached to a laden
jar
well what he did was as clouds were
passing over
he and his son william went out into a
field
and as the rain started they flew the
kite and they tried to draw the
electricity down from the clouds because
it was his theory that the lightning
strike was just a spark coming out of a
cloud
and at first it didn't work but as the
cloud got nearer you could see the
little fibers on the silk you know get
raised and there was a key at the end of
it
and that's where the uh the electricity
the
the charge collected and then he was
able to put it into uh a laden jar or a
battery right so really what he was
doing is he was connecting because the
clouds are getting a they're kind of at
a different electric potential up here
he by kind of connecting it with this
conducting silk thread that's wet he was
able to kind of get the laden jar at the
same potential right as the clasp it
wasn't like the lightning struck like
back no it wasn't like lightning
striking him he was drawing some of the
charge down from the cloud but that
showed him that what lightning was was a
discharge from the cloud of its electric
potential right right right and and
that's significant because when he
figured that out that you could
manipulate electro that lightning was
electricity
that he could kind of solve the the
church big big problem if you look at
that kite you've drawn what does that
show you it says i get it if we put
something up there like that like a
lightning rod and he knew that pointed
metal objects were very good
at drawing the flow of electricity so he
said why don't we put up a lightning rod
and he described exactly how to do it
they ended up testing it in france first
because he published
the lightning rod
way of doing it
but later on he uh replicates the
experiments in the united states it
makes him the most famous person
probably other than maybe the king of
france and the king of england the most
famous person in the world because he
has solved
this astonishingly uh a big problem of
how do we ward off lightning from
striking our buildings especially tall
buildings especially tall buildings and
castle towers and this already saves
lives this is a oh saves you know
hundreds of lives by far the most
important invention of the time
and of course we still use lightning
rods we still ground have grounded
points on top of buildings to make sure
you know that's a very simple idea if
you give kind of this pointed conductor
point that's really high up the
lightning will want to strike that and
then you can you construct a path for
the lightning so it can go to the ground
so that you give a path for light so it
can go to the ground and not have to go
through the building and you know what
he does in his house in philadelphia
especially because he's about to go to
england again at the time he puts up a
lightning rod he grounds it but he puts
a tiny little bell
so that when the electricity is coming
down from the storm is approaching and
it's drawing the electrical charge from
the cloud
a tiny little bell will sort of bounce
back and forth uh being jolted by the
charges coming there and it drove
deborah reed his wife
absolutely to distraction so there's a
wonderful letter he writes home from
england telling her how to dismantle the
bell and it will still be safe
fascinating